[Music]
breaking tonight former
georgia senator david perdue has filed
with the federal election commission
he's fired paperwork there today to
become a candidate to run for senate in
perdue who lost reelection to senator
jon ossoff during georgia's senate
runoff
election on january 5th filed that
paperwork designating a principal
campaign committee titled purdue for
senate
he would run against rafael warnock
currently the other senator from georgia
white house deputy press secretary tj
ducklow has resigned ducklow was
initially suspended for issuing a
sexist and profane threat to a
journalist seeking to cover his
relationship
with another reporter ducklow issued a
statement saturday expressing his regret
embarrassment and quote disgust for his
behavior
it is the first departure from the new
white house less than a month
into president biden's tenure the
political